it was a piece of cake for me when we
had 200 employees all in New York I
could walk by someone and know something
was wrong and address it now I have
people telling me that they don't feel
the culture and I'm like you work remote
every day by
yourself like what do you want me to
send send a ban to your house
like I dat trade attention and build
businesses Legacy is greater than
currency I'm a pure entrepreneur for
real for real for real like
[Music]
documented I'm thrilled to talk about
like the intricacies of like project
management and slack if you want to go
that narrow or we can go this heady cuz
all of it's interesting and I'm curious
in all of it and I like it all thrilled
to open it up if anyone feels overly
compelled with anything how do you find
violence like between family and work by
realizing it es and flows like if I
asked everyone to go around right now
and explain to me in full detail for 5
minutes how you define work life balance
we would have overlaps but it's
different but I think the thing that
works for me is understanding that
there's moments in time I don't think
there is perfection and work life
balance I think that as long as you have
intent to do right by yourself and the
people you love and do the best you can
and some days are better than others but
like I'm not crippled by that I just
don't think anyone's allowed to Define
work life balance except you and your
family and that's what you spend your
time on trying your best what do you
think is the biggest challenge that
we're facing as an agency and how do you
think we can overcome that challenge how
many people here have worked at another
agency raise your hand so for those
individuals with six or seven the
biggest challenge is whatever they're
bringing to the office that's
subconscious of Prior behaviors cuz we
do play different the other biggest
problem is the majority of everybody
else didn't raise their hand and they
don't have the contextual ization of
like how different this is those are
micro issues I think the the biggest
challenge we face is how to not be a
corporation we're a big company now and
no matter how much I try and even though
it all stems from the top I can't
control how 2,000 people at vaynerx
interact every second of every day and
so how do I create a macro framework
that continues to Champion the best
behavior and start to suffocate out the
worst behavior the world is complicated
and sells fear we have this four walls
that's trying to sell the reverse but
it's hard to fully trust it when every
other variable outside of it is doing
the reverse and so that's a big
challenge what do you think would be
fundamental to keeping us from that
corporate the only reason corporations
are corporations is cuz they actually
don't care and I don't blame them it's
not like I have judgment they want their
public stock or they want to sell the
company like I I don't really blame
things because I'm empathe atic to
everything for me what corporate
represents is indifference and cogs in a
wheel and not giving a [__] and I feel
very confident that I can't lose that
net net I'm really proud of who we are
but I'm not naive I know as happy as the
majority of the people here are some are
not happy and I want to always make it
better but I don't think we will lose
that but it was a piece of cake for me
when we had 200 employees all in New
York when we were 200 and all in New
York and I was there every minute with
them every minute 5 days a week in the
office it was easy I could walk by
someone and know something was wrong and
address it now I have people telling me
that they don't feel the culture and I'm
like you work remote every day by
yourself like what do you want me to
send send a band to your house like like
you know like so like these are the
things I'm thinking about what's like
the morning and night routine that you
follow I'm trying to model that I think
that people get caught up too much in
tactics like I feel like everyone's
focused on the sink instead of the well
everything I do at night and in the
morning morning is the same thing that
I'm doing right this nanc which is I
keep things incredibly simple I really
feel like I'm incredibly fortunate by
the circumstances of how I see the world
I'm really incapable of being upset
about things that don't matter and
almost everything doesn't matter besides
Health the only thing I could wish all
of you is just the ability to be
self-aware enough to put yourself in a
position to not be upset about like I
promise you every person in this room is
upset about something that like really
doesn't mean anything like think about
the [__] you're upset about in high
school like like a pimple or like a
grade or like think about how silly that
is well right now you're upset about
[__] that like in 20 years you're going
be like what the [__] was I doing it's
why I believe in our culture it's why I
hope most of you are having a good
experience here and when I say I hope
most of you having a good experience I'm
not naive that there's a million
variables I also can't control clients
so there's that whole reality right but
you know I spend all my time trying to
eliminate fear here that's what this is
right now please
like know how real my inbox for you is
if you're scared to email me then you're
not taking advantage of what's Happening
Here the thing that hurts me the most is
when people leave this company and they
didn't take advantage of what was
happening here I'm not delusional I know
not everyone is going to work their
entire career here but I do want
everyone to feel like the time they
spent here whether it's a year or 6
months or 6 years was like really really
good and fundamentally good we we want
to give that to you so please take it
especially for the most cynical in here
now I mean this like this is a place
that can maybe change your relationship
with cynicism may help you learn how to
start to trust take advantage of what's
Happening Here please cuz I promise you
if you don't you will think back to this
in 5 years
promise